on the mound for the marlins the first
guy to get three starts in his season
this year it's pablo lopez he has looked
good last time out against the mets don
mattingly said wasn't as sharp as he's
been but still looked
pretty good travis darnold the braves
catcher having a good road trip
seven for 21. and he jumps on the first
one and cracks this one deep toward left
field that ball's got a chance and that
ball
is gonna fly out of marlins park a first
pitch home run for darneau
and atlanta has scored in the first it's
one nothing
darnell went up there looking first
pitch fastball and got it
[Applause]
third homer for darneau well it's good
lineup that kyle wright's going to be
facing tonight
and coming off a good start his last
timeout
and another ground ball this one right
to freddie freeman how about that first
inning for kyle wright
three outs on four pitches he leads one
nothing after one
jonathan vr who scored 111 runs
hit 24 homers stole 40 bags
playoff pitch to vr is a liner over
third fair just barely down the line
sierra around third sprinting toward the
plate and then at second base with an
rbi double jonathan vr were tied at one
in the third
got it off the end of the bat and he hit
it just hard enough to get it over riley
the third baseman
the question was would it land fair foul
and it was just maybe a
foot inside that foul line again the
runners will be set in motion three
balls two strikes
and a bases loaded walk will give the
marlins a 2-1 lead here in the third
three consecutive walks issued by right
adam duvall had a little nubber hit off
the end of the bat
to the right side of the infield takes a
look at marcakus at second now the pitch
swung on hit hard to center field sierra
on the run he's not going to get it
that's going to split the gap
it one hops the wall marcakis is going
to score to tie the game
and on his way to second base with a
double is adam duvall
back to back two out doubles from
marcakus and duval a little two out
lightning
and it's two to two does square he gets
it down
and a double clutch by dayton out at
first and a
late start there forever as he weighed
and waited waited
and then comes in to score oh this is
where you start to get crazy up here in
the booth because you see
exciting baseball like we just saw
absolutely beautiful bunt by sierra
fantastic read by alvarez
braves have had their way with the
marlins last two years 15-4 last year
29 wins the last two years against miami
vr goes throw goes all the way to
second base and it's bobbled by swanson
marlins steal a run
oh you just do a double steal either way
fastball wild pitch double
steal we left that out didn't we how big
is that 90 feet on the long flight away
listen you're not doing double steals
without a runner on third base is loaded
in a two-run game
in the fifth slow roller to third and he
bare hands throws and he gets
them at first what a play by brian
anderson
boy i tell you what brian anderson can
play some third base the geico make it
easy play of the game holly was anything
but
easy when you've got that kind of arm
and you're able to throw
with that kind of velocity ball out of
hand to first base you can just trust
everything else is going to go
smoothly he's such a good athlete i mean
the quick release look how much he gets
on that throw he throws ozuna out by two
steps
honestly he takes the drama out of an
exciting play he made it boring
camargo left field long run joyce
takes the catch deep in the corner matt
joyce runs a mile to get to it
takes away extra bases from johan
camargo
joyce ranging deep into the corner to
make this play
yeah this is a special play look at matt
he has so much ground to cover and then
just
selling out to the back end i mean as an
outfielder
this is all you got he's a righty and
left field so for a lefty that would
maybe be a little bit more natural of a
catch
two balls two strikes birdie off
first and on the move ground ball
through the hole the base hit birdie on
his way to third
and sierra now heading towards second
the throw
is not in time yeah i love it so
aggressive on the bases sierra putting
pressure on the defense
and the marlins have two in scoring
position oh
man the little stutter step kind of
baiting a right fielder to just get the
ball back in casually
and here is a high fly ball center field
inciarte getting under this he's got an
arm
here's the catch at the at third base
tag
and coming home birdie scores the run a
sac
fly for aguilar and the marlins have a
5-2 lead
a run in on the aguilar sac fly sierra
bouncing off the second
and here it comes from jackson ground
ball past riley
green light for sierra rounding third
here's the throw from
left it's late up to second goes
dickerson
and it's a 6-2 marlins lead
man they just keep pouring it on oh they
got a broken bat double tonight the rest
of their hits have all been singles
cervelli alvarez vr chance to blow it
open sac fly is last time up
chance for even more ribbies here with
two outs that's a liner and it's off the
glove of swanson trickles into center
field
alvarez is around third he'll score
marlons get two on the play
riding away partner riding the wave
comes through
again i mean the speed of this marlins
group
a ground ball to short vr up with it
it's a marlins win